Unfortunately, now we get to the irresponsible
one I have today, the perfect sort of mind
meld for you of two completely lunatic factions
who have designated themselves coronavirus
experts in recent weeks.
You've got Fox News host.
And then you've got religious nuts.
Now, when I say religious nuts, I don't mean
everybody who's religious in the last segment.
We had Catholic priest Father Murray saying,
stay the hell home.
No churches on Easter.
Priests are dying.
You've got to do the responsible thing.
So when I say religious nuts, I don't mean
anybody who's religious.
I'm talking specifically about religious nuts.
So on the one hand, we've previously mentioned
absolutely unhinged.
Fox News former Judge Jeanine Pirro, including
her seemingly drunk broadcast last week or
the week before.
That's on on one side.
On the other side, we've talked about these
religious grifters talking about sin is what
caused Corona virus.
Prayer is the solution to Corona virus.
This clip today is a combination of the two
top religious grifter, Franklin Graham, son
of the late Billy Graham, a family of Christian
evangelists, was invited onto Judge Denise
Fox News show.
And it is as wacky and weaponized as you could
imagine.
So let's get right into it.
You won't be surprised.
Franklin Graham says it is sin that has caused
the virus.
Judge Jeanine loves it.
Let's break it all down.
And to Janine's credit, she asks a good question
why would God allow Corona virus to happen?
She's not asking the question in good faith.
She's teeing up a specific answer for Graham.
But at least she's asking the question.
Take a listen.
Given the number of Americans thousands have
already died, you know, you must get questions
like, why would God allow this kind of thing
to happen?
Well, I don't think he's got a plan for this
to happen to us because of the sin that's
in the world.
Judge Man has turned his back on God.
We have sinned against him and we need to
ask for God's forgiveness.
And that's what Easter is all about us, about
God.
So love in the world that he gave his only
begotten son.
God didn't plan it.
The sin caused it to happen.
Judge, says Franklin Graham, and noticed him
throwing Easter in their Easter, of course,
sort of canceled since the country will remain
closed.
No doubt many churches in certain parts of
the country will be filled with people on
Easter regardless.
So then Franklin Graham continues with this
line of reasoning.
And if you're watching, pay attention to the
look on Judge Janine's face.
Like this is some incredible new idea that
Franklin Graham is putting out there, that
whosoever believeth in him shall not perish,
but should have everlasting life.
Jesus Christ came to save sinners.
I didn't come to condemn the world, but to
save the world.
And if we put our faith and trust in him,
he'll forgive our sins and heal our hearts
and he'll change the course of our lives.
And this this pandemic, this is a result of
a fallen world, a world that has turned his
back on God.
And so I would encourage people to pray and
just let's ask God.
Let's ask God for help.
Well, Franklin Graham, I don't think there's
any question, but this is giving people a
tremendous opportunity to be somewhat introspective.
There it is.
If we trust Jesus, he will forgive our sins
and it'll change our lives.
And the pandemic is because we've turned our
back.
Just pray.
Praying is the solution.
So there are going to be people who see this
and they will say, quite simply, there's nothing
wrong with this.
It's a man of faith.
And he says we must maintain our faith through
the crisis.
That's not what Franklin Graham is doing here.
Franklin Graham is appearing on a channel
that's been minimizing and downplaying the
pandemic from day one.
And then they feed to their audience.
A guy who says the virus is caused by sin
and solved by prayer.
And we need Jesus in our lives at this particular
time.
The solution is social distancing, letting
the medical experts tell us what to do.
Work on therapeutics, work on a vaccine science
and staying the hell home.
Those are the solutions.
And when these Fox News viewers here, Franklin
Graham, insist the cause is sin and the solution
is prayer, they are more likely to keep packing
the churches and potentially becoming super
spreaders of the disease.
And that dumb look on Judge Janine's face
like what a breakthrough.
Incredible breakthrough from Franklin Graham
here on the virus.
It's disgusting.
Yes.
But it's not altogether surprising for Judge
Jeanine.
The message is this isn't about anything other
than people didn't pray correctly or they
didn't pray enough.
And it's actually flat out vile to be people
perpetuating that idea.
What about all of the good praying Christians,
by the way, who did die of the virus?
I guess according to Graham, they weren't
praying hard enough or their sins outweighed
the prayer or they pray to the wrong God or
work.
God works in mysterious ways or what?
You're not allowed to ask that.
That's an offensive question to people like
Franklin Graham.
The problem is, in reality, almost the opposite
of what Franklin Graham says.
Too many people are ignoring science and doctors.
The problem is not people are ignoring Jesus.
And instead they're listening to pastors and
clueless presidents like the one that we have.
And of course, this is a one size fits all
explanation for these religious nuts.
Jerry Falwell after 9/11 said it was the abortionists
and the gays that caused 9/11 to happen.
Others said the same thing about HIV.
Oh, definitely.
Sin was the reason for HIV.
These are horrible people.
They are only making the problem worse.
And Fox News continues to incubate for lack
of a better term, these ideas.
And unfortunately, again, sticking with the
viral vocabulary, a lot of Fox News viewers
have been inoculated against reason and rationality.
And they take this stuff as if it were gospel,
which Franklin Graham, of course, probably
believes it to be.
Unless he's just a straight up grifter, which
he may be, in which case he's a bad person
rather than delusional.
You often can't really tell with these guys.